football pod in america my treat goes
off please keep watching
i'm liam mchugh tony dungy is here
rodney harrison is here mike glorio
is here happy thanksgiving everybody
this is the best football week of the
year we get the three games on thursday
we get
then full slate on sunday but we're
gonna start with what happened on monday
night football the bucks lose again this
time to the rams brady two more picks
now is nine on the season that's more
than he had
all last year guys this is a team that a
month ago had those dominant
back-to-back wins green bay and las
vegas
tony i'll start with you how deep how
serious do you think their issues are
right now in tampa bay
well i don't think they're totally bad
but
the environment here certainly has
changed we've gone from hey who are we
going to play in the super bowl to i
don't know if we can win another game
in the city and you know really it came
down to two bad throws by tom brady he
played pretty well
the two deep balls down the middle
whether they were overthrows they got
away from him
uh they just didn't look good and they
came at the wrong time
defensively they're still going to be
fine jared goff had a good game
good game plan got rid of the ball quick
but
they can play with anybody it's just a
matter of how consistent they're going
to be
and i believe coach said their priority
has to be and their first priority
number one has to be to protect tom
brady
and we've talked about it you've gone
against time we've talked about it the
last decade when he feels pressure
he's just not the same quarterback and
they put pressure on him
they hit him and maybe the question
maybe the solution is go six-man
protection go seven-man protection maybe
get one or two guys
less in pass routes to protect tom brady
because that has to be the number one
priority if you can't protect him
then we see he's forcing the ball down
the field doing things that he's not
comfortable with doing
yeah they've got to figure out their
offensive identity against the panthers
we saw a lot of two tight ends they got
it working that way
when tom brady is expected to throw the
ball down the field and maybe he wants
to guys maybe
after a week that began with kyla murray
and russell wilson in prime time on
thursday patrick mahomes in prime time
on sunday
and then a rematch with jared goff from
super bowl 53
prime time monday night maybe tom brady
wanted to throw the ball down the field
maybe he has a little too much influence
over that offense
he was one for nine of throws 15 yards
or more with two interceptions last
night
they can't throw the ball down the field
he doesn't have time to do it
it's not working they have to get back
to two tight ends run the ball
set up play action and throw out of
those formations if they want to be
consistently effective
bruce arian spoke a lot about the
execution of the plays but
mike i mean what it sounds like you're
saying is maybe this needs
an adjustment from the coaching
standpoint you got to get back to
certain things that work for you
i think at some point bruce arians has
to step in and really say this is how
we are going to be this is what we are
going to do
i don't know whether or not maybe byron
leftwich is a little too deferential
to tom maybe tom wants to be throwing
the ball down the field and throwing the
ball
all over the place and showing everyone
he can still do what he used to do
i don't know where this is coming from
but they're too
inconsistent in their overall approach
they have to figure out what their
identity is it can't change every week
they have the pieces to have a good
offense but it's not going to be a good
offense if tom brady's dropping back in
the pocket
can't move out of the pocket make
something happen and has to get rid of
the ball before the walls cave in on him
because
we saw it last night the walls are going
to cave in on it hey mike i don't think
this is
i don't think this is tom brady's doing
i mean we've seen tom brady in the same
system for the last two decades tom
wants to run the football
he wants to get the rid of the ball
quickly play action pass
eventually come out in empty formation
get rid of the ball quickly
i think this is more bruce ariens and
byron leftwich influence as opposed to
tom brady
i just i don't think tom brady is the
one to drop back and want to just
throw the ball down the field because
time's not about stats time is about
trying to win the football game
so whatever it takes whether he throws
the ball for 150 yards or he throws the
ball for 350 yards
tom's not caught up in his stats that's
something that bruce arians has to do a
better job of getting tom and doing
what's comfortable with tom
all this down the field throws i mean
think about tom brady he's got nine
interceptions
right now that's one more than he had
all last year so they're forcing the
ball and then you look at jameis winston
it
seems like everybody in bruce aryan
system they throw interceptions jamie
winston had 33
tom has nine so you have to look at the
coach
well and when they were really effective
if you look at it the empty sets
throwing the ball fast getting it to
antonio brown
getting it to all their playmakers
quickly and then taking your shots off
play action they would bring the two
tight ends in three tight ends
and now you got gronkowski or you've got
mike evans
on one on one situations you've got
protection and throw the ball down the
field and it's been effective but just
lining up as you say dropping back
trying to throw those
25 yard post routes and those fades
that hasn't been there so i i do agree
with you rodney i think looking at the
style of play
and how they do it uh they can be fine
and coach you talk about their defense
earlier and what i've noticed is
they have a tremendous amount of
athletes across the board
but they play too much zone and sitting
back and
good quarterbacks eat up zone coverage
especially you don't have a lot of
pressure and i just think they have to
go and start implementing a little bit
more man-to-man coverage
and that's really been a weakness in
their secondary and that's the big
question is secondary we know they got
physical safeties they got some athletes
on the outside
but can these guys hold up in man-to-man
coverage that's a big question
listen all the headlines are going to be
about tom brady and rightfully so you
figure everything he's done all the
weapons he has around him but on the
other side of this
you know tony i'm curious the rams
defense the way they're playing right
now does that have you believing that
the rams could be a team that
represent the nfc in the super bowl i do
like the rams rodney talks about being
able to play man coverage
they've got that they've got pass
rushers uh they
last year they had trouble stopping the
run but they seemed like
with this new system they're playing
better run defense
and obviously their their offense is
going to score points they played from
ahead a lot
so uh i i think the rams are as tough as
anybody in the nfc
the problem with all these teams are
nobody's playing consistent ball
we watched tampa bay against green bay
and we saw tampa's the best team
we watched new orleans take tampa apart
tampa's the best team
but everybody's having these up and down
games who can string together five or
six weeks in a row of good football
and coach you know what i like about
their defense it's no longer
all aaron donald you see brockers you
see leonard floyd you see the secondary
stepping up and i remember at the
buffalo game i was very disappointed in
their secondary
because they didn't look like they had
any intensity any continuity
they were missing a bunch of tackles and
ever since that game it's like
each week they've gotten better they've
they've improved in coverage they
improved in tackling and jalen ramsey
he's been outstanding
and coach the point you made is an
excellent one in the afc
we know it's the steelers and the chiefs
in the nfc
we change our mind every week and right
now
for now at least the rams look to be as
balanced as anyone but you know what so
do the saints and i wish those two teams
would play at some point
during the regular season so we could
settle it on the field maybe we'll
settle it again in the playoffs like a
couple of years ago
well hopefully not with the ending we
had a couple of years ago but rodney
before we move on
did you compliment jared goff there
i just want to rewind for a second were
you saying jared got
i've always said country club mr country
club is a good quarterback but you know
sometimes in those tight
situations
[Laughter]
to that point though rodney third down
and eight
last night to win the game they ran the
ball
yeah and that that tells you something
yeah it's something about trust and
there's a compliment in there
even if it's added with the country club
do it
rodney one thing you did say over the
weekend though you did say best
defense in the league belongs to the new
orleans saints right now
you have to say the last three games
definitely been superb what three points
against the bucks not blow out on our
game on sunday night 13 points against
the 49ers then nine points against a
falcons team that usually even if they
lose
puts up some points have a couple days
to digest this
you looked at the numbers around the
league you sticking with us saints best
defense of the nfl
hey liam forget about the stats and all
those other things the most important
thing is how
how where you're playing and like coach
say if you're playing consistent you
look at that front seven
their ability to get after the
quarterback hendrickson cameron jordan
demaro davis has been absolutely
outstanding he's one of the best
linebackers if not the best middle
linebacker in all of football
you look at a guy like chauncey
gardner-johnson who's just been a
symbolism
of just versatility playing different
positions the energy the physicality all
those different things
and remember earlier in the year malcolm
jenkins he struggled he was playing
terrible i'm looking at him like
he's gotten old he's lost the step now
he's starting to play
a lot better so they're going to be even
even better
once marshawn lattimore gets back
well my problem though with new orleans
is you see these type of games and
you'll see a quarter or three quarters
like that and then you'll see a couple
of plays where guys are running wide
open
and you say what's going on in that
secondary i think when they concentrate
when they're on their game
they are as good as anybody i've just
seen a little bit too much roller
coaster
and maybe they're going to get that out
of them and play that consistent ball in
november and december
tony who do you think has the best
defense of the league
i i don't see a great defense out there
and i i see up and down performance
and um i think the rams and new orleans
are playing as well
as anybody right now but you can look at
other games early in the season where
you don't see that so
yeah uh i'm not sure who has the best
defense right now
guys i'll tell you the top three
defenses as i see it i would say the
saints
the rams and uh who's the other team i
just forgot about the rams the saints
and oh the pittsburgh steelers yeah the
pittsburgh steelers
mike can you disagree with that florio
well look i
i think the steelers have the best
players on defense at every level it's
just
we've seen too many times this year
where they're not dominant and the
offense has to bail them out you know
as they keep winning game after game
after game but they're not
dominant weekly and they do have to to
find a way to just outscore a team that
they should beat by 10 15
20 or more points but i think they have
the star potential
at every level which is going to serve
them well when the playoffs roll around
so florio you think that a defense has
hold on one second coach
you think a defense has to show
dominance every single week in order to
show that they're good
or do you look at it like the pittsburgh
steelers even
against lesser competition they're
finding ways to win
well i i i look at it as they're not a
dominant defense unless they're
dominating on a regular basis but
they're good enough
to bend but not break like they did
against the ravens i think the ravens
game was indicative of what the steelers
are this year from time to time they are
going to line up against teams that we
look at and say
they're not as good as that team like
the chiefs i hope that those two teams
cross paths in the playoffs
because the chiefs will be favored but
the steelers will
quite possibly find a way to win because
that's what they do
regardless of whether it's a lesser team
or a better team riding point you made
over the weekend it's the nfl they're
all good teams even the bad teams are
good
and if you're able to win every single
week you're doing something right
and the steelers are doing something
right on both sides of the ball and on
special teams
the two things that steeler defense does
well which you need to win a super bowl
they take the football away
and they can rush the passer they don't
play consistent all the time they don't
they're not always in their gaps they're
not always great for 60 minutes
but in crunch time they take the ball
away and they can rush the passer
and coach the last point that i was
thinking when you watch their tape they
don't get discouraged when you hit
a big play on them defensively because
they just feel like they have so much
talent you talked about how much talent
they have florio
but even when they get in the red zone
they have so much confidence and their
ability to take the ball away
they don't panic they just stay calm
they wait for that pass rush
and you see minka one of those guys
making big plays
yeah and tony to your earlier point
about the idea that maybe there isn't a
great defense because we don't see it
week in week out
i mean it wasn't that long ago i think
you'd have to have the ravens right at
the top of this list
defensively yeah and this is a team that
was the top seed the afc last year right
now
on the bubble on the outside looking in
they dropped the back-to-back gains
and then you look ahead to our game
thursday night against the steelers
you're not gonna have mark ingram you're
not gonna jk dobbins you're not going to
brandon williams all because of cover
related issues
this matchup it's interesting because
this is a team that overcame some cover
related issues when they beat
indianapolis but now this seems like
a lot to overcome in a big moment
against a massive opponent
and i think it's going to be their
defense that has to come through
pittsburgh the last couple of times
they've played lamar jackson
they've confused them and he hasn't been
great he's they've moved the ball but
they've turned it over
they haven't been that dominant running
team so i think this defense is going to
have to go in and shut them down they're
going to have to think maybe a 17 point
20 points at the most and i haven't seen
that from this defense in the last few
weeks
they've got to get that swagger back and
if you're the ravens this is the most
important week of the season
because you're coming off consecutive
losses and you have some doubts and
things like that
now you can't be in in the facility
around your teammates around your
coaches
you know it's different like when i'm in
studio with you guys me and mike floria
we're in the studio with you guys
hanging out is totally different but
from being on zoom calls
because when you're there you get a
chance to really interact with your
coaches see guys
face to face you know the tone of the
room it's just totally different i think
that's going to have an effect on them
short week two straight losses working
virtually
going to pittsburgh the ravens are on
the ropes and the challenge for the
steelers is going to be punching
them through and and the steelers have
the ability to do it mike tomlin said
yesterday they have to match the ravens
desperation but the ravens are going to
be desperate on thursday night
the question is will they have a fair
opportunity to be ready for this game
when they have missed their practice
time this week because the facility is
shut down and they're doing everything
via zoom call rodney you're right it's
not the same
especially if you're trying to get ready
for a football game hey floria i wanted
to ask a question because i was
wondering about
mark ingram and you see he was really
the energizer bunny i thought he was
you know as lamar was the mvp last year
but lamar was really
to me the energy of that team like
what's going on with him with him not
getting refs is he still
hurt or are they just going in a
different direction with because of j.k
dobbins
i think that during the period that mark
ingram missed the ravens were able to
come to the conclusion that it's time to
move forward with jk dobbins next year
ingram is due to make five million
dollars for a running back
that is a lot of money he's been around
since 2011 when he was a first round
pick of the saints
it's just reaching the natural end of
the road for ingram because of the
position he plays and i think the ravens
understand if they want to
to sustain this at some point they need
to be ready to reload that position and
i think that's where they're going but
they're not going to have either guy
on thursday night it's gus edwards
because both ingram and dobbins tested
positive they will not be back in time
for the game
and these are the games the steelers
typically
we haven't seen great performances oh
they don't have their running backs
they've got a short week they haven't
been playing great
covered and you would see the steelers
go out and maybe play a lesser game but
i think
the fact that it's baltimore and the
bitterness of that rivalry
uh we're going to see the steelers play
well
knock them out now you can you don't
want to see them in january knock them
out now while you can
well and i wonder if we see the ravens
elevate their physical play because
i'm curious rodney bigger concern coming
off the weekend
lamar jackson the lack of sort of big
plays and splash plays or the fact that
time
that raven's defense looks like looked
like he got bullied he got pushed around
a bit
well we know about lamar jackson we know
these young quarterbacks still trying to
develop
still trying to figure it out so he's
going to be up and down to a certain
degree
but to me it's more concerning with that
defense and that defense was
always built on their reputation of
being tough guys being
physical and really controlled on the
line of scrimmage and i just haven't
seen them do it this year
we saw them get completely run through
with the patriots we saw it against the
tennessee titans and to me
when i'm if as a db if i'm seeing our
guys get run through up front i'm like
i'm discouraged because that's the heart
and soul of our defense
right there but they need those guys
back kayla's campbell um
williams all right of course earlier on
thanksgiving it's the cowboys against
the football team it is
andy dalton against alex smith just how
everyone planted at the beginning of the
year
listen is it a great matchup no is it an
important matchup
yes because the winner of this game is
going to temporarily at least take over
the top spot in the nfc's
nothing really gives me greater pleasure
than asking on this magical mystery tour
of nc east how you think
one of these matchups is going to play
out
mike gloria i'll start with you what do
you see happening
well what's gonna happen is barring a
tie on thursday and i can't rule out a
tie with the nfc east teams
somebody will have doubled their win
total for the entire season in a
five-day stretch from sunday
to thursday because both dallas and
washington won and you know it's still a
big game there's going to be 30 million
people who tune in
even if half of us are in a
turkey-induced coma but it's still going
to be something that we pay attention to
it always feels bigger on on
thanksgiving
right the lights seem brighter at the
cowboys stadium they have the big
salvation army kettle there
maybe ezekiel will jump into it again
and whoever wins that game is going to
develop a glow an
aura a shine that they can be the team
that takes over the division and
you know with the eagles not being able
to find their own way i really do think
whoever wins this team is going to get a
lift they get a mini buy
going into the final five games and
they're going to feel good about
themselves
hitting the stretch run and you know the
cowboys i think are the best team on
paper
they just consistently over the past
several years haven't been able to live
up to their potential
if they can pull this one off especially
after how badly they looked against the
washington team when they played earlier
this year it could give the cowboys the
boost they need to try to steal the
division
look guys this is not a marquee match-up
okay go ahead coach if you want to go
no i was gonna say i honestly believe
they could do it and make a little run
uh andy dalton is a good quarterback if
they have enough passing game and we've
seen cd lamb come on they've got
receivers
that's going to help elliott they've got
enough talent where if they
feel hey we're coming back we're getting
healthy we can do something
they could get on a little run and and
be problematic here in in december
i agree with you coach as far as the
dallas cowboys but to me it's it's a
little different because i look at alex
smith and
and being a guy that gone had gone
through such a terrible
knee injury myself i just look at alex
smith and what he's been able to do
to to rehab and the toughness and the
mental toughness that it takes
to rehab yourself back to where you're
playing on the football field he's
blessed enough to be able to play on
thanksgiving
and andy dalton last time we saw him
he's getting his head knocked off
nobody's coming to his rescue but it's
really good to see these guys
and i do and i do believe what you say
coach like andy dalton has a chance i
mean he's an experienced quarterback in
this league
he can make some plays he's got the
weapons around him and i look forward to
seeing
ezekiel elliott um get hot and and
really get it going
and mike you're right it's a big game
both teams come into this one red
hot riding identical one game winning
questions
cowboys coming off that win over
minnesota which was sparked by mike
mccarthy
doing his best gallagher impression on
saturday night
team meeting before the game and he's
trying to inspire some guys so he gets a
real
sledgehammer gets some watermelons they
write the objectives for the game
on the watermelons and he goes out there
and just starts smashing them
teams going wild demarcus lawrence
apparently got in on the act
this is next level motivation uh so i'm
curious
from you guys the best motivational
speech
you've seen or just heard of
during your time in the game rodney
start with you
i'll go um super bowl i think it was
super bowl 38 when coach belichick
um he came in and coach belichick when
you spend time with him he gives you
bits and pieces and stuff like that and
the conversation is pretty all
pretty much always short but he came in
there he talked about
how important it was for us to stick
together as a team and what it meant to
win a super bowl
and the price that you have to pay in
order to win a super bowl and what it
means down the line
in your life um the hair um just the
legacy and everything that you lead
man after that speech because i've never
heard anything really like that from
coach belichick i wanted to run through
a brick wall
but i knew once i left that meeting room
that we were definitely going to win
that super bowl
for me liam 2006 afc championship
game we're down 21-6 to um
the patriots rodney's team at halftime i
knew it was desperation situation so i
borrowed one that i'd heard bum phillips
say years before men
we're playing terrible if we don't start
playing better fast we're gonna lose
and look the guy who's got the least
football experience will go last but
i'll tell you here's an example of how
things just burn into your brain when
you're young i was 10 years old
first year of playing organized football
we were in the
catholic league championship and getting
our butts kicked at halftime and
i don't play i only got in when we were
up 35 nothing which happened a few times
that year but i'm sitting on one of the
benches in the locker room and the coach
comes in and he kicks this cardboard box
and it hits right next to me and orange
peels go flying
everywhere and everybody got quiet and
everybody listened and it didn't make a
difference we still got our butts kicked
mike what position did you play i was a
lineman
short and fat put him on there you know
it's funny
you know it's funny because when when i
coach youth football
all the kids we loved all the kids of
course but the scrubby kids like mike
florio
you just take and you put them on a
defensive line and you kind of hide them
because
there was always a minimum amount of
plays that you had to play
10 plays so i'm taking florio and i'm
putting them at
the defensive tackle for 10 plays and
then you're out of there mike
we didn't have enough players to do a
full scrimmage in practice so i'm a
fifth grader and i was the nose tackle
and the center i was like looking up at
a california redwood tree and thankfully
he wasn't a bully he could have killed
me every practice if he wanted to and he
didn't
i love that scrubby kid is a term of
endearment there
from bradley absolutely listen no one's
got less football experience than i do
uh i played soccer my whole life i
played soccer in college but i had a
college teammate tell me about a
motivational speech that he got from his
high school coach
back in the day there was a kid on the
team whose dad had been the town mayor
and he had just lost his bid for
re-election
now this kid wasn't the most talented
player on the team but he'd been playing
really hard he'd been playing well
so the coach kind of singled him out and
he's like hey davis the way you're
playing the way you're running around
the way you're doing things
everyone needs to play like that
everyone needs to model themselves
after you in fact davis you're playing
so well
next time i'm going to vote for your dad
now get out there
[Laughter]
inspirational words i think what this
tells us liam is motivational speeches
are overrated huh
yeah definitely let me just say this let
me put a button on it with this
now it was a different time in the 70s
and coaches were able to do different
things but
the coach of my grade school team if you
were loafing
if you were lollygagging if you weren't
getting it done you got a foot in your
butt or you got dragged around by your
face mask
and to this day one of the reasons i
never stand still
i still and maybe this isn't a good
thing but i still fear that that foot is
going to hit me right in the butt
or somebody's going to grab me by the
face mask and drag me around so i always
keep moving guys
hey coach i asked one of your ex players
i'm not going to tell you which player
i said um i know coach is kind of a
reserve guy
like what did he do to get you motivated
and he said coach never had to say
really anything and really you provided
him with perspective
but he said we loved and respected coach
so much we knew how important it was and
the time that he spent
we wanted to go out there and always win
for coach so your players man
they got so much love for you coach you
didn't have to go screaming and throwing
things
and throwing chairs and stuff hey
sometimes it's about love sometimes you
just don't want to disappoint someone
sometimes it's about taking a
sledgehammer and smashing
watermelons it just depends what works
for your guys
listen guys always great to chat with
you looking forward to this weekend
looking forward to thursday night
happy thanksgiving to you all
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports